こんにちははじめ殺王です皆さん
僕の歌引いたことありますでしょあの自分で言うのもなんですけどもを政治にも甘く
ないんですよ
でっかいいだ
ああああああ
deai
なんですけどうまくなりたいじゃあどうすればいいのか5位取れずルー氏がない
でしょう
今回こちらから選んでおりますどうぞ
use as 歌ってみたどぅーどぅだって usa さんに入っていただいてあっ
エロ組織しまーぬーをもう聞かせ頂きましたねはい
ズバリ道ですん
分
ん
15点ぐらいです
ブーブー言いませんかね
8 us キャティロソの pooh pro さん
を買いレーニングを私受けますと輝く乗ってますか
でますだはじめちゃん始めちゃったよ癖いきます音ズレちゃんは割れが出てるんですよ
お医者は誰かが出てるんですけどだんだん恋しくなって言ってだんだん最後
悲鳴だよああああブーバーちゃんとスター nude なるほどは1回でバー見てみ
ます
スプーンぬーんですけどこんな感じですどうぞ
ジャッキー no day
ひいいいいか i are you doing
いいいい
c んがぁダースと現場ですが現状ですね
どうですかポイントでここは強くなかってみてやっぱりですねあのまあ高いところ
だんだんきつくなくて剤が姿勢が今ちょっといただけないです知ってあることでもええ
文章ですね苦しくなる時エコー首が前に出ちゃう
ああああ確かにそう
そうなんです鉱脈日の前にまあを図1号が消えてしまったんです
なるほどですねそう姿勢がまずはよくないとか
あとお腹にめちゃめちゃ力入っていいと思うんですよねお腹に力を入れちゃうと呼吸が
うまく出来ないでその甲羅の長さになってくるとか
load load そうし制定呼吸が止まっ発生
のバランスこれを止めていくと3 days after が本当ですからんざいまし
た
ん
ちょっとあんまりイングランドはで生まれですけどポイント嬉しいんじゃないんですよ
ね一番がヘタすぎてそのコーンの現在生きるのかとか思うん
終わりました2週間1週間私にくださいそしたら絶対歌い許してみてます
うっ
じゃあまずはピアノと一緒にこれはです選んだけど
none うーん
せーのああ
par ああああ
ああああああああ
ああああああ
んああああ
あああああふわぁ
入っていまイレギュラー
歌うためには女子でさあ城瑞場で出せるようにならなきゃいけません
b 0 e
rania none
ad それが落ちる sasano
al
イレブンの言われ中に小さく比べね
me
dare
いいいけると結構良いっぽくなっちゃう2つでの女性だっちゃですよ
まずは小さく字堀出せる範囲をちょっとずらしてきます
なるほどよねはい裏五いねえだろけどまぁもちろんカーン自由に食べたんですけど力
じゃないですね
んでー
[音楽]
ブーバー1パリィ可姉一気とって ana 練習できるように音源ヒアロスしかねえん
だろそれ
育児しっとりとかをしていきたいと思っておりますじゃあもう一ヶ
部分
アースキーホルダー
[音楽]
登りたいに行きましょう
ronin
数16はじめちゃちょっと気持ちを得ません
ああボイトレっていうかさっきの猫の発生土でも大切なんですけど体の姿勢部品
めっちゃ解説で
じゃあこのついでに1回佐布里ましょうそれはまずですね歌いで一番重要なのは
方向の顎の筋肉野郎ケア月ここ f
ない痛い人痛いと言いますこれか言ってアホ脅して15分予測やなきゃってなるだけだ
から茹でるだけでいっぱいありますよねっ
今文ですよ小顔効果もあります柔らかくなるのでたくさんネットハイ車油に気をつけろ
するあれ両方に押します期待まあよ
気持ちイイネルっ
パワー借りたようん
[音楽]
ブーブー女神ですけど絶対
必要ですなるほどこれも毎日やるとかの方がいっぱいにちょっと後にか主義ですね前
よろしいですねちょっと合うわけで
した覚えてしまう
ちょっと頭から親指前に移動させ
上日の篤人このスターも出すに降ってしまうような孫の真ん前が何でしょうか
[音楽]
ブーブー8あー坊ブーブしろっブーブー言っ
ブーブー言っは
yeah
オゾンじゃあ呼吸の話したい行きましょうか一番動かしたいのはこの
肋骨を八郎するこうした
こっち持っレッドポーズをとって
ブーブー s worth はっはい
一どうぞ0 ne
nar 言うんですね
イレギュラー3つ下なんですよ
pou dou dou
[拍手]
rar
ni
にイレギュラーが2こ下までは今
ブービーしっかりできればうれしいけどちょっとこっちからどぅんでニール見えてる
あああっっでロス
ゆっ生します
はっはっはっはー
me
aname
いいいい
yeah
me
しません
いいいいいいこれ
[音楽]
tale
yeah yeah
いいいいい
[音楽]
pale
me
nao
car
ale
ママムービーかけたあー
もう彼で彼だけはやめなって
これは甘みではなかったよ
回ところをため息っぽく歌えるとカッコよくデー
hey ぽって
意識のその中にい
[音楽]
[拍手]
市はハイルーン
では戦小沢しますお邪魔しましょうねありがとうございましたお礼たらございました
本当にいいねを知らさんやばい
今習っただけでめっちゃ濃い買ったんですよ本当に
という間の一週間ことです
最終日でございますお知らせてサポート取ってすと思います最後はリジー
頑張りますこう言ってもねそんなにで外声だしすぎるとの杭ためちゃうんで結構長期
ために
見捨てる長だったいつもドリスに使われます
me
rar
うーむうーんちょっと今やると声かねそうなのでこんなもんにしておきますでは芦田
スタジオで撮ってきます
お楽しみに
ん
ああああああ
エイ
car
me
tan tan
[音楽]
いいいいいいいいいい
me
22 f
僕が見つめる景色のその中に君が入ってから変わり果てた世界はいつも一つなくに
こなした日々の真ん中不思議な引力に逆らえ
作ら触れてくっ
間
なんてっ
言いかけてはやめて
排卵アイナー何度も
高まるああ
なかった
ある信者の中
3000棟カヤ役薄型
腕ずっとの中に飛び越え追って解けた絵の具みたいな
yeah
1人だなぁ
ギター気付けなかったろう
ni
[音楽]
ani
真立つ届ける君にい
だけだろ
i am
その寸キュア僕ら
car
[音楽]
rel
1個
のところとかもバットカーぺット社のなのはありますね
2分